Ricki go here what's that a switch
that's right yes so apparently you can
shut off the stream of your sperm just
like a light switch
yeah that makes sense let's do people
nice tree think about that so a German
invention just recently released a
device that you can turn off the flow of
your sperm wow really yeah they just
develop something that stops the flow
strong that's bad that's bad news but
like a light switch you can turn it on
and off oh cool you're going out nothing
lady that you want to spend the rest of
your life with the woman in your life
cold yep go time I feel like this is a
great idea you can choose what you want
to have recreate reproduce and that's
fantastic it's good that's a really good
question so let's go do the trial period
right now they're looking for people to
try it out to bring it to market right
right
would you be willing to be one of those
men to try this thing out well first of
all I mean I try just about anything but
that's kind of a stress sure why not
hey really live once right yeah so why
not it's right I dig that no not at all
really
yeah I don't want to buy it mr. Martin
my joint is private but you like without
me and you like that idea yeah just not
for me nope
I wouldn't so my thing is this do what's
safe yeah do what's mature you know and
do what what what allows you to continue
and enjoy the beautiful aspect of lovely
got that kids here it is on auto
pregnancies now